en effet la quinzaine de ressortissants
albanais qui s'est installée ici au
jardin du vallon des rigolettes il y a
maintenant quatre mois est sommé de
quitter les lieux d'ici samedi soir 48
heures de délai donc qui rappelle deux
autres cas ici à mâcon
l'évacuation du parking monnier c'était
fin décembre et surtout celle de la
place de la barre où s'étaient installés
17 adultes et neuf enfants tous
demandeurs d'asile qui ont été évacués
fin décembre et qui avaient été relogés
dans un gymnase durant six mois il faut
savoir que les albanais et les 15
personnes est balèze qui sont présentes
ici compte trouver très rapidement un
autre point de chute